well I think there are several ways
first of all if they know specifically
the areas of interest to them on the
left-hand side of the home page we have
a list of categories so they go from
meta which are the sort of broad topics
that are not physical like truth and
wisdom love and happiness the type of
things that have been left out of the
general conversation I think of late and
we try we're trying to bring that back
into discourse and then the second
portion of the site is physical so
things that are sort of obvious like
technology business medicine that type
of thing and so you could you know the
user could look through the categories
and click on those or on the homepage we
have a list of four features in the top
window that we've created based upon
users so it could be is the American
political system broken features that
we've sort of put together on specific
topics with different people answering
the same question or speaking to the
same subject one could also click on the
expert Network there's a tab which is at
the top left now and we'll be moving a
little bit further up actually which
lists all the experts so when you click
on them you'll see a list of all of them
that are up and that will be growing
daily and so really sort of just by kind
of testing and looking around the site
you can work your way through it but
there is definite order to it
I think the biggest mistake is by
staying just on the homepage and not
looking around and also not joining the
conversation so I mean you asked for the
biggest mistake maybe the biggest
mistake is not joining the conversation
I think that everybody's opinion matters
and actually the way to sort of
catalyzed changes to have everybody
participate and especially shy people
who all too often don't and it really
don't have to participate in a way that
is public in that your face doesn't have
to be shown or you don't have to leave a
video you can do it by pictures or audio
or or text hopefully video is the way
you'll do it but there is all manner of
ways to participate so there's really no
reason why people shouldn't well five of
us write the blog and everybody who's
working on Team big think and basically
it's kind of a way to highlight some of
the content we have on the site and also
to relate what's going on in the Daily
News and daily world to what's on our
site to show that they're sort of
intertwined and they are and also it's
it's it's useful for us to figure out
what's going on in the news and see the
stories that we should be following
ourselves
when you click on any category there'll
be a feature in the top window and it
could be just one person answering a
specific question or it could be you
know several up to 10 people talking
about a specific topic area and so a
feature is in essence a based upon a
general theme or a question and its
portions of interviews that we have
pulled out the with people speaking to
this theme or question and it's on a
specific topic so it's it's usually
quite short they're in between maybe 1
30 seconds to 2 minute responses and so
you can compare the way people have
answered the question so say for
instance you know people speaking about
what the big issues of the next election
should be you could see you know what my
Gravelle has said versus Peter teal vs
Larry Summers versus Moby and so you get
to see people from very different walks
of life talking about the same issue
well I think something that is not
evident now and will be evidence soon is
we have our own interview platform which
is to interview experts from afar so if
there and say Sweden and we're here
instead of having to traveler them
having to come here we can actually
interview them real time about their
areas of expertise and so the expert
network in in more finite subjects and
more specific subjects will be growing
and so you'll be able to come back and
see doctors speaking about health
matters or business people speaking
about specific things going on in
business and that will be much more
tangible and real information that's
accessible in specific subject areas
rather than broad questions that will be
growing will also still be maintaining
the larger themed content because that's
you know what a lot of people are
interested in to the user participation
will definitely be growing
and we'll be listening to feedback from
but what users want and incorporating
their ideas as well into into that but
for in the immediate term I see the
expert Network growing quickly and also
just more and more content on the site
and most importantly participation from
the people who are coming to it